Você sabia que aquele café da manhã
antes do exame pode ter estragado todo o
seu resultado? Pois é, muita gente não
sabe, mas existem erros simples que
compromete completamente os exames de
sangue. Olha só, o primeiro erro
clássico, ficar sem beber água. Galera,
jejum jejum de água. Mantenha-se bem
hidratado. Segundo erro, fazer jejum
quando não precisa. Hoje em dia, nem
todos os exames precisam mais daquelas
12 horas torturantes de jejum. Terceiro
ponto que ninguém te conta, aquele
suplemento de biotina para cabelo pode
bagunçar os seus hormônios no resultado.
Pare ele 72 horas antes. Quarto erro,
esse é interessante, mudar completamente
a alimentação antes do exame. Não
adianta virar santo na véspera. O exame
tem que ser reflexo da sua rotina real.
Quinto, treinou pesado ontem, espera 24
horas para colher, senão sua secar e
outras enzimas vão pro espaço. E sexto,
sempre avise todos os remédios,
suplementos que você toma mesmo aquela
vitamina C inocente. Na próxima coleta,
lembra dessas dicas? Compartilha com
aquele amigo que vive reclamando que os
exames dele dão sempre alterados. Às
vezes o problema não é a saúde, é o
preparo.